HERE MODERN ONE,
THISIS
MINNESOTA DO BU
WITH LEONARDEE.
>>
FINALLY A LITTLE RHYTHM IN THIS
WEDNESDAY.
OH! TO
FOR WESTBROOK WITH ALL THE
HANDS OF TIME.
BIG-TIME PUTBACK AND F F
LAURENT, FIRST TO STAY IN, DOWN
25-16 LARGEST LEAD FOR PHOENIX
BURKS COMES UP WITH THE
BASKETBALL AND TOPPIN AHEAD OF
THE FIELD AND SLAMS S N
THEIR FEET WATCHING FROM THEAT.
>> Dave: MCDANIELS WIDE OPEN.
GRIZZLIES PROFITABILITY TO COME
UP ES FROM
POWELL.
SIMONS ON THE ATTACK. THE NIGHT
OR THE DUNK
OH, MAMAMAMAMAMA
GREAT PASS.
THE FOUL IS ON GRAYSON ALLEN,
HIS SECOND.
>> LOU HAD HAVE KARL-ANTHONY T
INJURY
[LAUGHTER]BY FIVE.TOO HIGH?
THE BALL IS BEHIND AND
THE HASHTAKEOFF.
HE IS NOT GETTING HIS WAY.IT ST
BA
LL